what's with the jeans do you remember a
few weeks ago we had the twins and they
were like yeah at the same time yeah we
have a different set of crazy twins boy
they wear the same clothes they both
have tattooed eyebrows they yeah they
are they're they're the same and they
have they have something they'd like to
share the world's most identical twins
and they're both my Australian weren't
the other ones they're either they're
both more you get you realize it this
whole thing is a product of the
Kardashian of course it is or Barbie
like this which is dumb yeah
why the whole lip so uh it's so bizarre
it's just such a bizarre timing you
think everything's fake yeah it's so
weird this is the this is the standard
now and constantly post videos of
themselves to their YouTube channel and
they're actively the same from the hair
to their match your wardrobe of
the season and their matching asshole
themed boyfriend here they are on
Australia's Sun Rise show Ross we've had
separate boyfriends in the past and it
hasn't worked but now it's much easier
and yeah it's great cause we're happy
we're with each other 24/7 me and my
sister it's just must easier to share a
boyfriend because we're always together
according to Australian report
winds are just what's with the eyebrows
what's with everything from es the
eyebrows the Lord standard issue with I
can't focus with the lips I can't focus
cuz the eyebrows
yeah the lips are distracting to me I'm
looking at them like I don't know
what's going on but I but she just they
just took sharpies and like the chola
brow because they're trying to fit that
ideal they're so damaged make me look
like him please so damaged yeah I want
to be Bobby yeah yeah let's dancing
their future if one gets pregnant the
other will follow suit so their bodies
stay exactly the same
so they're both dating the same guy so
he's dumping clips left and right yeah
both of them I guess that's the only
plus but isn't that the big fantasy for
a guide to be banging twins yeah but
this is the rare occasion where the
trends really want to do that most twins
go go now yeah they go grows and I want
to have my own you know boyfriend yeah
yeah I like one person's come and meet
like my own yeah you don't really want
to share and like it's really private
these two are real I mean they must know
they might even do that whole other like
maybe they're like incestuous and
they're just they might be I don't know
why these girls just don't make the leap
and do porn I kind of feel like that's
on the table that's coming up yeah
they're only there one phone call away
from it yeah do you think there might be
a one phone call away from the the
greatest porn leaf of all time that no
one's ever only gotten anyone to do and
that is to get them to be with each
other no one's ever gotten that no I
think with the thing is they've had
twins do porn but twins you know
siblings typically won't touch each
other
oh you've thoroughly research the genre
like you've done the research into it
yeah and I think these two would
actually go yeah no problem
yeah I'll eat out my entire identical
twin sister yeah there's some of that
going yeah yeah that's weird
they're definitely weird look how long
I've gone without burping right now can
we just acknowledge that first horse
for that matter
ever since before the show